algo que ha resultado sumamente afectado
Durante este año de guerra pues han sido
las instalaciones sanitarias es solo un
estimado son alrededor de 500 ataques lo
que ha sufrido esta red a lo largo y
ancho del país y para hablar justamente
de salud y de otras de otros temas
relacionados con este ámbito nos
acompañan el estudio nuestra compañera
mar Romero mar bienvenida Muchas gracias
a todos Bueno vamos a decir que pues
después de un año de esta invasión una
de las principales víctimas como ya lo
estábamos mencionando ha sido justamente
este sistema de salud Así es Valentina
partíamos de un sistema de salud
bastante sólido no planeo al final es un
país europeo que tenía algunos problemas
algunos deficiencias pero que tenía una
red bastante extendida atención
sanitaria y que un año después ahora eso
es una sombra de lo que era repasamos
esas cifras que estabas mencionando de
la Organización Mundial de la Salud en
este año de conflictos se han registrado
cuarenta y siete ataques a
infraestructuras sanitaria estamos
hablando de hospitales pero también
centros de salud diversos también se
cuentan las ambulancias sobre todo en
zonas del este de Ucrania pero también
en zonas más en el oeste de Ucrania
hasta hasta el birsen registrado ataques
contra la infraestructura sanitaria se
calcula también que aproximadamente uno
de cada 10 hospitales ucranianos está
dañado pero no solo la infraestructura
también son los trabajadores de la salud
131 trabajadores de la salud han quedado
heridos y 101 han llegado a perder la
vida Todo esto sin contar los que han
sufrido también de otras formas se han
registrado decenas de restos han habido
retenciones han habido secuestros han
habido hospitales que se quedan sin luz
sin energía aunque no hayan recibido un
ataque directo y es un momento pues
imprescindible para recordar que al
final en estos lugares de salud estos
centros de salud suelen ser lugares de
vínculo comunitario no también y que al
atacar no solo atacan la atención a la
salud sino también atacan estas
referencias de la institucionalidad y
las referencias de las comunidades Marc
a propósito de lo que usted menciona de
estas afectaciones a los centros de
salud uno de los ejemplos que dio la
vuelta al mundo fue el bombardeo al
hospital de Mario Paul cuéntanos sí
recordamos estoy segura que todos
recordamos esas imágenes de una mujer
embarazada saliendo de un hospital
materno infantil que había sido
bombardeado en marúpula esta ciudad
portuaria que ahora ha quedado pues bajo
dominio del ejército ruso después de
días y días de bombardeos muy intensos
en durante el mes de marzo sobre todo el
año pasado el 80% de la infraestructura
sanitaria de esta ciudad por ejemplo
está destruida como un ejemplo eso que
decíamoslo como más al este más cerca
del conflicto más daños hay sobre la
infraestructura y estas cifras y
particularmente este caso de Mario Paul
nos hizo abrir mucho debate sobre si
está siendo una estrategia deliberada
militar rusa atacar estas
infraestructuras sanitarias o no hay un
Rango de opiniones amplio aquí pero lo
que no hay dudas que al final este tipo
de ataques son una infracción flagrante
del derecho internacional eso aquí
estamos viendo algunas imágenes de unos
doctores precisamente de mariopol que
escaparon de la ciudad después de este
asedio Ruso y que en quiebran abierto un
nuevo una nueva ala en un hospital para
seguir haciendo su trabajo ahora con
personas desplazadas del resto del país
recuerdan Cómo fueron los ataques y lo
vamos a escuchar
los soldados rusos llegaron al hospital
e implementaron sus propias reglas todos
los pisos estaban completamente
controlados por los soldados contaron a
los pacientes contaron los empleados
para que nadie se fuera dijeron que si
los doctores se iban les dispararían
si nuestros doctores especialistas y
todos los que conocemos cada vez que
hablamos nos decimos que es sin duda
volveremos Mario Paul es Ucrania
Cuáles son las consecuencias sobre la
salud de esta falta de infraestructura
si estábamos hablando de esta
infraestructura destruida o de la
interrupción de luz y energía y todo eso
Tiene un gran impacto sobre el acceso a
la salud sobre todo de los ucranianos
según de nuevo un informe de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud uno de
cada tres ucranianos buscó acceder a
tener atención primaria en Ucrania este
último año una proporción bastante más
alta de lo que sería en un país pues que
no estuviera viviendo un conflicto y la
mitad encontró barreras en ese acceso a
la salud no logró tuvo dificultades para
conseguir la atención que necesitaba
además uno de cada cinco no consiguió la
medicación necesaria para tratar sus
condiciones algo que se eleva a uno de
cada tres es decir un tercio de la
población en caso de zonas ocupadas o en
conflicto entrevistamos a Pepe Fernández
que es director de médicos del mundo que
nos daba más detalles es decir hay un
cúmulo de circunstancias que generan una
situación de altísima precariedad en
todo lo que podamos Llamar sistema
sanitario infraestructuras de asistencia
sanitaria de hecho la otra gran
circunstancia Es que la población que
tiene dificultades adicionales de
movilidad como puede ser la población
mayor o las personas con cualquier tipo
de discapacidad que afecte a la
autonomía en cuanto a la movilidad
tienen prácticamente imposible el acceso
a los servicios sanitarios uno de los
problemas que usted mencionaba ayer a la
falta de acceso a medicamentos cuéntenos
más acerca de ello sí puede ser o bien
por problemas de seguridad y de
desplazamiento dentro del país pero
también por la interrupción de las
cadenas de suministros y por los
problemas económicos derivados de la
guerra hay cifras de nuevo sobre el
informe de la Organización Mundial de la
Salud sobre los medicamentos que más
faltan vemos que los que más escasean
son todos los medicamentos que tengan
que ver con la presión sanguínea alta o
enfermedades cardiovasculares calmantes
antibióticos también que es pues muy
preocupante sobre todo una zona de
guerra donde se necesitan antibióticos
para tratar posibles infecciones
derivadas de las heridas y las razones
que se citan son principalmente el
aumento de precios del 84%, y por falta
de disponibilidad en la farmacia
entonces vemos eso como todos estos
medicamentos que ya nos dan pistas
también de Quiénes son los más afec en
este conflicto bueno Omar Quiénes son le
pregunto a usted pero también se lo
pregunto a nuestra invitada quiénes son
Realmente los más afectados por estas
interrupciones en el sistema sanitario
podemos hablar de una población en
particular o estamos hablando del grueso
del pueblo ucraniano sí antes de seguir
interviniendo queríamos Escuchar una de
esas respuestas que nos dio precisamente
Pepe Fernández de médicos del mundo
escuchémoslo toda la carga de enfermeras
vamos a llamar por llamar Crónica por
ponerle una denominación me estoy
refiriendo por ejemplo a personas con
diabetes con insuficiencia renal con
hipertensión con otras enfermedades
cardiovasculares con cáncer todos estos
procesos se han visto
afectados en la continuidad de los
tratamientos por la ruptura también de
los stocks de medicamentos y de otros
productos y equipos sanitarios mar Ahora
sí retomo a preguntarle Y a usted
también a nuestra invitada Anita Cuál es
Quién son las personas más afectadas por
estas interrupciones en el sistema
sanitario podemos hablar grupos
específicos más afectados o el grueso de
la población se ve completamente
afectada vamos es decir que en las zonas
donde hay bombardeos sufre toda la
población civil pero personas que no se
pueden mover que son ancianos y no
pueden salir de sus casas esto significa
para ellos una falta de posibilidad de
salvar sus vidas y que decir de los
padres los padres con Los pequeños niños
que tenían que tomar una opción no
pueden enviar los niños si son muy
pequeños pero que estén en otro lugar en
otro país si no están con ellos y vamos
a hablar y defectos sobre todo el medio
ambiente hemos visto muchos cuadros en
donde se ven personas que se evacuan con
sus mascotas y donde de la naturaleza
este quiere de verdad no se hace
recortar el concepto de la guerra total
todos son afectados y de la misma forma
que todos son afectados en el concepto
de guerra total también sucede ese
concepto de salud global no lo que
afecta una la economía afecta a la salud
lo que afecta al medio ambiente afecta a
la salud entonces son muchas las aristas
que se ven aquí también yo por mi parte
quería recordar todos esos pacientes que
necesitan tratamiento como hablaba El
doctor no y de un diabetes pero también
por ejemplo las personas que viven con
VIH que necesitan acceso a
antirretrovirales y que no necesitan
estar necesariamente en zonas de un
conflicto muy intenso Para que vean
interrumpido esa necesidad y pues para
poder tener esos tratamientos o los
pacientes de cáncer que sabemos que es
muy grave que tengan sus tratamientos
interrumpidos Entonces como vemos son
distintas las cosas que suceden en el
este del Oeste Pero al final afecta a
todo el mundo mar y a largo plazo Cómo
puede impactar en la salud esta
situación de conflicto claro la guerra
por ahora parece que vaya a acabarse
pronto al menos así en un corto plazo y
Hay consecuencias que ya estamos viendo
como estas que estábamos mencionando
pero también hay consecuencias a largo
plazo en los próximos años precisamente
también de eso nos contaban desde
médicos del mundo
ha habido Por una parte carencias en la
detección precoz o en la detección de
muchos problemas de salud que cuando
emerjan pues van a tener un nivel de
extensión y de gravedad mayor que el que
pudieran haber tenido de haberse
detectado previamente y luego las
enfermedades ya crónicas que requieren
un seguimiento de un control en el
tiempo Pues también
pues tienen que aparecer pues
agravamientos y secuelas por falta de
por falta de control esta carga de
enfermedades de los próximos años que
estaban mencionando también sucede por
esas pruebas diagnósticas que no se van
a estar haciendo Durante este año de
guerra precoces que no se logran
enfermedades que no se tratan a tiempo
que van a empeorar Y por supuesto
también por vacunas que no se van a
estar poniendo Durante este tiempo
aunque también pues hemos hecho un poco
de investigación al respecto parece que
por ahora Gracias a mantener condiciones
de higiene en general de acceso agua
potable más o menos pues dignas parece
que se están manteniendo a raya las
enfermedades infecciosas pero si se
prolonga el conflicto no podemos
descartar que a todo esto que estamos
mencionando se añadan también pues
brotes o epidemias de enfermedades de
infecciosas en